[Music]
scientists have mapped more of
mars than the ocean floor on earth
it's very cold there's no light at all
there's crushing pressures
so how can life exist there and yet it
does in great
abundance in the past 20 years
deep sea explorers and marine biologists
have discovered
thousands of new species and vast
ecosystems
but the remotest part of the planet has
also attracted massive
interest from one of the biggest global
industries
mining the deep ocean floor is packed
with minerals needed for a more
environmentally sustainable future
but at what cost there's a possibility
that we could lose species before we
even knew they existed
[Music]
in the middle of the atlantic ocean on
board the rss
james cook marine biologist kerry howell
and a team of scientists are mapping the
unknown
if you're thinking about what have we
actually looked at on the sea floor
it's less than 0.001
but you have to remember it's vast it's
70 percent of our planet this ocean
and all of that 70 90 of that
is deep sea so it's a huge huge area
and difficult to get to
with the help of isis a four-ton vehicle
operated from the ship's control room
they can plunge to depths of six
kilometers
the deepsea is really classed from about
200
meters and it goes all the way down to
11 kilometers deep which is the bottom
of the mariana trench
the huge machine is fitted with five
cameras and robotic arms which collect
samples of marine life it's this huge
ecosystem that consisting of many
different types of habitats and species
with every deep water mission scientists
like kerry are able to build a better
picture of the ocean floor
and the areas that could be most
affected by human activities
so when we're out in the deep sea we
collect physical specimens
but we mostly are collecting video of
the sea floor
and of the animals in situ so in their
natural habitat
so that we can study how those animals
live
how they interact with other animals and
the sorts of roles they have
in that ecosystem these images
also reveal the resources critical for a
green revolution
people have been looking at the deep sea
as a potential source of
metals and particularly rare earth
elements that
are useful to humans and are used in
many electronic devices
mineral-rich deposits have been found in
three different areas of the ocean
on abyssal plains flat areas of the sea
floor
a polymetallic nodules potato-like rocks
that contain
iron nickel copper cobalt and manganese
sulfide deposits with lead zinc gold and
silver
have been discovered near hydrothermal
vents
and some underwater mountains have rich
cobalt crusts
the metals that are contained within
these resources things like
copper lithium are used in things like
batteries
the argument that is being made is that
we need these metals to help with the
green revolution so
renewable energy sector particularly
electric cars these sorts of things
use these metals in their production
current land mining practices are known
to cause severe environmental problems
from loss of biodiversity soil erosion
and pollution mining of some elements
such as cobalt
is centered in poor countries where
children are known to carry out
dangerous work
it's calculated that by 2050 demand for
cobalt and nickel will be four times
greater than the available reserves on
land
now mining companies and some policy
makers are making the case that the path
to a greener future will have to include
extracting these minerals from the ocean
floor
although it's more difficult mining
companies can extract the same metals
from a single location on the ocean
floor as they can from two or three
mines on land
if a country has mineral resource within
its exclusive economic zone so that's
the area of ocean
around the country that it's responsible
for
then um it's it's up to that nation's
government whether or not they choose to
use that and japan has actually just
recently gone ahead and successfully
demonstrated the first deep sea mining
in their own waters
in international waters so this is what
we call the high seas or the area
is the seabed that is managed by
a un authority called the international
seabed authority
and it's managed on behalf of all of
mankind
and all nations
the international seabed authority or
isa
has issued 30 exploration licenses to
hunt for precious metals
the clarion clipperton zone a 6 million
square kilometer area in the eastern
central pacific ocean
is of particular interest it is
estimated to hold three to six times
more cobalt in its reserves
than all known land-based reserves
combined
but the ccz is also rich in newly
discovered marine life
i think one of the worries about deep
sea mining is
that because we are finding brand new
species in these areas
there's a possibility that we could lose
species before we even knew they existed
and some of those species could not only
benefit deep sea
ecosystems but human health
the bacteria that are living in the
sponges we're interested in them to see
what
antibacterial compounds they produce
on land kerry has teamed up with matt
upton
a scientist with a specific interest in
antibiotics
antibiotic resistance is is a major
threat it's one of the biggest threats
to
global human health so we need to find
new antibiotics
discovering antibiotics in natural
environments was something that i was
already
actively doing it's just when kerry came
with the sponges it seemed to be an
opportunity to look at some really
strange and unusual samples deep sea
sponges have been around for over 600
million
years and produce antimicrobial
compounds that matte hopes could be used
to make new antibiotics
we know for certain some of the things
we found are new
we know for certain some of the things
that we found
kill the sorts of bacteria that we want
to be able to kill like
staph aureus and e coli the very first
sponge samples that kerry gave to matt
produced astonishing results when we
started this we didn't know what we
would find
so i was surprised that we found things
that that had activity that that killed
these and other bacteria some of the
early work went really really well
and we got some very encouraging results
it's early days but if matt is
successful
an antibiotic derived from the deep sea
would be hugely valuable
the biomedical potential of these
samples
could be immense and so we need to look
at the bacteria in those environments
and look at the samples
to explore that and understand that in a
bit more detail before we go ahead and
potentially destroy some of those
environments and lose
access to those medical benefits
successful mining applications may well
be granted within the next few years
as with mining on land mining the deep
sea will most likely cause huge
disturbances to localize deep water
ecosystems
but the knock-on effects could be
catastrophic
the deep sea performs a number of
services for people
it locks up carbon which mitigates
climate change
it absorbs heat it recycles nutrients
which support our fisheries and it's
these other types of service
that we get from the deepsea that we
don't even think about and
i would like to see just a greater
understanding of the potential impacts
so that we can make
a much more informed decision about
whether we do or don't mind the deep sea
with the demand for these essential
metals ever growing
governments will need to weigh up the
impacts of mining the sea
against mining the land my role as a
scientist
is really to provide the information to
society and governments and management
organizations
to help them to then understand the
sorts of trade-offs they might be making
when deciding about ocean use for
protectors like kerry
it's a race against time to explore and
understand the secrets of the deep
and ensure governments and mining
companies know the risks of exploiting
these pristine parts of the planet
[Music]
hi i'm claire and i directed this film
if you want to learn more about the
future of the oceans and the people
working to protect them
and click on the link opposite if you
want to learn more about the protector
series then click on the other link
please subscribe and thank you for
watching
you